kurdish human rights activist ismail
akbar wants to prevent young kurds from
joining the pkk
and taking up arms so every day he
drives to the villages around his
hometown of hakkari
first he speaks with the village elders
like here in the mountain village of
suman
because they're the ones the young
people listen to
believes that the peace process between
turkey and the kurds deserves another
chance
sooner or later both sides will have to
sit down together again and talk
so why not now before thousands are
killed again
a ceasefire lasted for two years
including here at the border with iran
but now the kurds anger can be felt
again in suman
the village is right next to an army
basement
we're afraid that we'll be shot at when
we go up to our flocks
but we're really fed up if they want war
again
then that's what they'll get
the men here say that under turkish
president recep tayyip erdogan
the government in ankara has been
inciting anti-kurdish sentiment
one man accuses the pro-kurdish hdp
party which ran a successful campaign in
the elections this past june
of doing nothing about it but akbalet
resists the negativity
peace wouldn't have been possible
without the hdp
and what's the alternative to talks war
means that this region will once again
suffer death and destruction
and no one benefits from that
but wool has already returned to the
area
a few kilometers away from the village
the turkish military set up a roadblock
after a roadside bomb exploded during
the night
and almost simultaneously a small truck
loaded with explosives blew up outside
an army barracks
footage from the funeral of a pkk member
shows how strongly the young people of
hakkari support the militant
organization
and that they're prepared to take a path
of martyrdom if necessary
and often their arguments are more
compelling than those of akbolot
after all making peace with the turkish
government didn't end the kurds poverty
these boys have to pile up pressed which
is used to heat their homes in the
winter
the pkk has no real trouble recruiting
them
the army helicopters fly over our homes
every day
people are arrested and if you go out on
the street it could happen that a bomb
explodes
we're fed up maybe we can't beat them
but they can't beat us either we're
talking about 40 years of repression
here
this has to end some way or another
on the streets of akpalet's hometown of
hikari things appear normal
but most people are too scared to
venture out at night
it reminds aquilet of the 1990s when
martial law was in place in the kurdish
regions
the military and police tortured people
villagers were torched
and hundreds of kurds disappeared
in 1996 this man was abducted by
soldiers along with seven other
shepherds and farmers
they were probably later killed but
their bodies were never recovered
the families were able to sue
successfully for compensation
in front of the european court of human
rights
and now once again we're mourning
civilian victims shot by security forces
kurdish regions of turkey
and pacifists like ismael are rare among
the kurdish people
you